inmunidad para el príncipe Mohamed
salman y cambio de discurso de biden
sobre el caso hashogigui la
administración estadounidense estableció
en un documento presentado ante la
justicia este jueves que Mohamed salman
goza de inmunidad en Estados Unidos al
ser jefe de un gobierno extranjero el
príncipe heredero saudí fue nombrado
Primer Ministro por decreto real a
finales de septiembre un nombramiento
que le permite escapar de procesos
judiciales que tiene abiertos en el
extranjero en Estados Unidos está
denunciado por atis sensik la ex
prometida del periodista Yamaha shogi
ati sensik ha compartido su indignación
el departamento de estado de Estados
Unidos ha otorgado inmunidad a Mohamed
minsalman no es la decisión que
esperábamos pensamos que tal vez habría
una luz para la justicia en Estados
Unidos Pero nuevamente el dinero ha
ganado
según la Casa Blanca acordar inmunidad
al príncipe saudí es una decisión
estrictamente jurídica y no tiene nada
que ver con el caso hashogui el
periodista crítico con el poder saudí
fue visto por última vez cuando entraba
en el consulado de Arabia Saudita en
Estambul el 2 de octubre de 2018 horas
antes de ser asesinado y descuartizado
por un grupo de agentes audífonos según
lo hacía la operación fue dirigida por
el mismo Mohamed vincelman a raíz del
asesinato de hashogui vaiden declaró que
trataría al régimen de riat como un
estado paria sin embargo chocó El puño
con el príncipe heredero en su visita a
la monarquía del Golfo en octubre el
presidente estadounidense anunció que
quería reevaluar la relación con Arabia
Saudita después de que la OPEP Plus se
posicionara del lado de Rusia al rebajar
la producción de petróleo